and first i want to express my deepest
gratitude to sue gray and all the people
who have contributed to this report
which i've placed in the library of this
house and which the government has
published in full today for everyone to
read
i will address its findings in this
statement
but firstly i want to say
sorry
and i'm sorry for the things we simply
didn't get right and also sorry for the
way that this matter has been handled
and it's no use
saying that this all that was within the
rules and it's no use saying that people
were working hard
[Applause]
this pandemic
was hard
for everyone
we asked people across this country to
make the most extraordinary sacrifices
not to meet loved ones not to visit
relatives before they died and i
understand the anger
that people feel
but mr speaker it isn't enough
to say sorry
this is a moment when let's look at
ourselves in the mirror
and we must learn
and while the metropolitan police must
yet complete their investigation
and that means there are no details of
specific events in sue grey's report
i of course accept
sue gray's general findings in full
and above all her recommendation that we
must learn from these events and act now
with respect to the events under police
investigation she says and i quote
no conclusions should be drawn or
inferences made from this other than it
is now for the police to consider the
relevant material in relation to those
incidents but more broadly she finds
that
there is significant learning to be
drawn from these events which must be
addressed immediately across government
this does not need to wait for the
police investigations to be concluded
that is why
we are making changes now
to the way downing street and the
cabinet office run
so that we can get on with the job the
job i was elected to do mr speaker and
the job that this government was elected
to do
first it is time to sort out what sue
grey rightly calls the fragmented and
complicated leadership structures of
downing street which she says have not
evolved sufficiently
to meet the demands of the expansion of
number 10
and we will do that
including by creating an office of the
prime minister with a permanent
secretary to lead number 10
[Music]
second mr speaker it is clear from sue
gray's report
that it is time not just to review the
civil service and special advisor codes
of conduct wherever necessary
to ensure that they take account of sue
grey's recommendations
but also to make sure that those codes
are properly enforced
and third
i will be saying more in the coming days
about the steps we will take to improve
the number 10 operation
and the work of the cabinet office to
strengthen
cabinet government
and to improve the vital connection
between
number 10
and parliament
mr speaker
i get it and i will fix it
and i want to say
[Applause]
and i want to say
to the people of this country
i know what the issue is
yes mr speaker yes
yes it's whether this government can be
trusted to deliver
and i say mr speaker yes we can be
trusted
yes we can be trusted to deliver we said
that we would get brexit done mr speaker
and we did
and we're setting up free ports around
the whole united kingdom i've been to
one of them today which is creating tens
of thousands of new jobs mr speaker we
said we would get this country through
covid and we did we delivered the
fastest vaccine rollout in europe and
the fastest booster program of any major
economy
so that we've been able to restore
people's freedoms faster than any
comparable economy
and at the same time we've been cutting
crime by 14 percent building for 40 new
hospitals and rolling out gigabit
broadband mr speaker and delivering all
the promises of our 2019 agenda so that
we have the fastest economic growth of
the g7 we have shown that we have done
things that people thought were
impossible mr speaker and
and that we can deliver for the british
people mr speaker
i just i remind the the bench is
opposite
the reason we're coming out of covid so
fast is at least partly because we
doubled the speed of the booster rollout
and i can tell the house and this
country
that we are going to bring the same
energy and commitment to getting on with
the job
to delivering for the british people and
to our mission to unite and level up
across this country mr speaker and i
commend this statement to the house
i don't call kirsten the leader of the
opposition
thank you mr speaker i'd like to thank
sue gray for the diligence and
professionalism with which she's carried
out her work it's no fault of hers that
she's only been able to produce an
update today not the full report
the prime minister repeatedly assured
the house that the guidance was followed
and the rules were followed
but we now know that 12 cases have
reached the threshold for criminal
investigation
which i remind the house means that
there is evidence of serious and
flagrant breaches of lockdown
including including the party on the
20th of may 2020 which we know the prime
minister attended
and the party on the 13th of november
2020 in the prime minister's flat
there can be no doubt that the prime
minister himself is now subject to
criminal investigation
the prime minister must keep his promise
to publish sue grey's report in full
when it is available
but it is already clear that the report
discloses the most damning conclusion
possible
over the last two years the british
public have been asked to make the most
heart-wrenching sacrifices
a collective
trauma
endured by all
enjoyed by none
funerals have been missed
dying relatives unvisited
every family has been marked by what
we've been through
and revelations about the promised
behavior have forced us all to rethink
and relive those darkest moments
many have been overcome by rage
by grief
and even guilt
guilt
that because they stuck to the law they
did not see their parents one last time
guilt that because they didn't bend the
rules
their children went months without
seeing friends
guilt that because they did as they were
asked they didn't go and visit lonely
relatives
but people shouldn't feel guilty
they should feel pride
in themselves and their country because
by abiding by those rules
they've saved the lives of people they
will probably never meet
they have shown the deep public spirit
and the love and respect for others that
has always characterized this nation at
its best
our national story about covert is one
of the people that stood up when they
were tested
but that will be forever tainted by the
behavior of this conservative prime
minister
by routinely breaking the rules he set
the prime minister took us all for fools
he held people sacrificing contempt he
showed himself unfit for office
his desperate denials since he was
exposed have only made matters worse
rather than come clean every step of the
way he's insulted the public's
intelligence
and now he's finally fallen back on his
usual excuse
it's everybody's fault but his
[Music]
they go
he stays
even now he is hiding behind a police
investigation into criminality into his
home and his office
mr speaker he gleefully treats what
should be a mark of shame as a welcome
shield
but prime minister the british public
aren't fools they never believed a word
of it
they think the prime minister should do
the decent thing and resign
[Music]
of course he won't
because he is a man without shame
and just as he has done throughout his
life he's damaged everyone and
everything around him along the way
his colleagues have spent weeks
defending the indefensible
touring the tv studios parroting his
absurd denials degrading themselves and
their offices
fraying the bond of trust between the
government
the member of south ripple is my
neighbor i expect better from my
neighbours
kirsten
fraying the bond of trust between the
government and the public eroding our
democracy and the rule of law
margaret thatcher once said
the first duty of government is to
uphold the law
if it tries to bob and weave and duck
around that duty when it's inconvenient
then so will the governed
mr speaker
to govern this country is an honor not a
birthright
it is an act of service to the british
people
not the keys to a court to parade to
your friends
it requires honesty integrity a moral
authority
i can't tell you how many times people
have said to me that this prime
minister's lack of integrity is somehow
priced in
that his behavior and character don't
matter
i have never accepted that
and i never will accept that
whatever your politics whichever party
you vote for honesty and decency matters
our great democracy depends on it
and cherishing and nurturing british
democracy is what it means to be
patriotic
there are members opposite who know that
and they know the prime minister is
incapable of it
the question they must now ask
themselves is what are they going to do
about it
they can heap their reputations the
reputation of their party the reputation
of this country on the bonfire that is
his leadership
or they can spare the country from a
prime minister totally unworthy of his
responsibilities
[Applause]
it is their duty to do so
they know better than anyone how
unsuitable he is for high office
many of them knew in their hearts that
we would inevitably come to this one day
and they know that as night follows day
continuing his leadership will mean
further misconduct cover-up and deceit
it is only they that can end this pass
the eyes of the country are upon them
they will be judged by the decisions
they take now
[Music]
well mr speaker
there's a reason why he said absolutely
nothing about the report
that was presented uh by this government
and later put in the library of the
house earlier on say that is because mr
speaker the report does absolutely
nothing to substantiate the tissue of
nonsense and he has just spoken
absolutely absolutely instead mr speaker
this this leader of the opposition a
former director of public prosecutions
mr speaker
he spent most of his time prosecuting
journalists and failing to prosecute
jimmy savile as far as i can make out mr
speaker
he mr speaker chose to use it chose to
use this moment to use this moment mr
speaker continually to pre-judge a
police inquiry that's what he chose to
do
he's reached his conclusions about it
i'm not going to reach any conclusions
and he would be entirely and entirely
wrong to do so and and i direct him
again mr speaker to what uh sue gray
says in her in her report about the
conclusions that can be drawn uh from uh
her inquiry about what the police may or
may not do now mr speaker i have
complete confidence in the police and i
hope that they will they will be allowed
simply to get on with their job and i
don't propose to offer any more
commentary about it and i don't believe
that he should either and i i must say
to him uh that what i think the car and
well i think the country with greatest
respect to the benches opposite what i
think the country wants us all in this
house to focus on
is the issues that matter to them
getting on mr speaker we're taking this
country forward and and mr speaker uh
today uh we have delivered yet more
brexit freedom to the new freeport uh in
tilbury as i said when he voted 48 times
to take this country back into the uh to
the eu
mr speaker we have the most open society
most open economy it's mr speaker this
is i think what people want us to focus
on we are the most open society most
open economy in europe because of the
vaccine rollout because of the booster
life and never forget mr speaker that he
voted he voted to keep us in the
european medicine agency which would
make that impossible and today mr
speaker we are standing together with
our nato allies against the potential
aggression of vladimir putin when he
wanted not so long ago to install a
prime minister as prime minister a
labour leader who would actually have
abolished nato mr speaker that's what he
believes in those are his priorities
what i can say to him he can continue
with his political opportunism we are
going to get on and i am going to get on
with the job
quiet
theresa may thank you mr speaker the
coverage regulations imposed significant
restrictions on the freedoms of members
of the public
they had a right to expect their prime
minister
to have read the rules to understand the
meaning of the rules and indeed those
around them to have done around him to
have done so too
and to set an example in following those
rules
what the grey report does show
is that number 10 downing street was not
observing the regulations they had
imposed on members of the public
so either my right honourable friend had
not read the rules or didn't understand
what they meant and others around him or
they didn't think the rules applied to
number 10 which was it
[Applause]
it's a very important question i want to
hear the answer even if other people
don't prime minister
no mr speaker that is not what the uh
grey report says
[Applause]
uh but if she i i i
suggest that she waits to see uh the
conclusion of the inquiry
i know come to the leader of the snp in
blackfoot
thank you mr speaker can i say it's a
pleasure to follow the
former prime minister and perhaps
her behavior in office like many that
went before her was about dignity about
the importance of the office of respect
of truthfulness and the prime minister
we would be well advised to focus on
those that have not dishonored the
office like he has done
mr speaker
we stand here today
faced with the systematic decimation of
public trust in government and the
institutions of the state and at its
heart
a prime minister
a prime minister
being investigated
by the police
so here we have it
the long-awaited sue grey report what a
farce
it was
carefully engineered to be
a fact-finding exercise
with no conclusions
now we find
it's a fact-finding exercise
with no facts
so
let's talk facts
the prime minister has told the house
that all guidance was completely
followed
there was no party
covered rules were followed in that
i believed it was a work event
nobody
nobody believed them then
and nobody
nobody believes you're now prime
minister
that is the crux
no ifs no buts
he has willfully willfully misled
parliament
[Applause]
sure
the prime minister inadvertently told
the house in the 8th of december that no
parties had taken place and then had to
admit that they had
it's bad enough mr speaker that the
prime minister's personal integrity is
in the ditch
but this murky business is tainting
everything around it
it is our intention
to submit a motion
instructing the prime minister to
publish the great report in full
well the prime minister
of being instruction by this house to
publish as required
mr speaker
amidst allegations of blackmail by tory
whips the members opposite
have been defending the indefensible
wait for the report we were told
well here it is
and it tells us very little except it
does state
that there were failures of leadership
and judgment by different parts of
number 10.
it states that some events should not
have been allowed to take place
that is the prime minister's
responsibility
if there is any honour
any honor in public life then he would
resign
where is this
and he laughs
and the prime minister laughs
we ought to remind ourselves in this
house
150 000 plus of our citizens have lost
their lives
family members that couldn't be with
them and that is the site that people
will remember a prime minister laughing
at our public i extend the hand of
friendship
to all those that have sacrificed
i certainly do not extend the hand of
friendship to the prime minister who is
no friend of mine
where is the shame
where is the dignity
meanwhile
the police investigation will drag on
and on
every moment the prime minister stays
trust in government and the rule of law
is ebbing away the litany of rule
breaking the culture of contempt the
utter disdain for the anguish felt by
the public who have sacrificed so much
what the public see
is a man who has debased the office of
prime minister shrinked responsibility
dogged accountability and blamed his
staff at every turn presiding over
slaves and corruption and tainted the
very institutions of the state in short
mr speaker this is a man
[Applause]
well they can laugh
they can laugh
but the public know
the public know this is a man they can
no longer trust he has been investigated
by the police he misled the house he
must now resign
honor
you'll have to withdraw that last
comment
mr speaker i gave the evidence of the
8th of december
you're going to have to withdraw misled
mr speaker the prime minister has misled
the house
[Applause]
unless you withdraw i will have to stop
and that's not good just withdraw the
words
i am standing up for my constituents
that know that this prime minister has
lied and misled the house
them in the paper
give me the paper
in a burton
i'll give you one more chance as leader
of the snp i don't want to have to throw
you out i'm going to give you this
chance please increase the power that
man has left out the house
shut up
i'm sorry it's come to this
and i'm sorry the leader of the party
has not got the decentred just withdraw
those words in order that this debate
can be represented by all political
leaders
would you like to inadvertently
if the prime minister has inadvertently
misled the house then i will state that
right we're going to leave it at that
prime minister
mr speaker i i'm
grateful to the uh right honourable
gentlemen withdrawing uh what he just
said because he was wrong then and uh
he i'm afraid is wrong in the in his
analysis and i i i apologize as i've
said for uh all the suffering that
people have had throughout this pandemic
and and for the anger that people feel
uh about uh what has taken place in in
number 10 down the street but i've got
i've got to tell
the uh the right honourable gentleman
that for much of what he said uh his
best course is simply to wait for the uh
for the inquiry to be completed
can i just say i take it the honourable
member that's withdrawn the right
honorable member
that the prime minister may have
inadvertently misled the house
to help me to help the house
you withdraw on your early comments and
replace it with inadvertently it's not
my fault if the prime minister can't be
trusted
[Applause]
under the power given to me by standing
order number 43 i ordered the honourable
member to withdraw immediately from the
house
it's all right we don't need to bother
right let us move on andrew mitchell
does my right honourable friend recall
that ever since he joined the party's
candidates list 30 years ago
until we got him into number 10 he has
enjoyed
my full-throated support
but i am deeply concerned by these
events and i'm very concerned indeed by
some of the things he has said from that
dispatch bot
and has said to the british public and
our constituents
when he kindly invited me to see him 10
days ago
i told him that i thought he should
think very carefully about what was now
in the best interests of our country and
of the conservative party and i have to
tell him he no longer enjoys my support
well uh
mr speaker i i must tell respectfully uh
my right honourable friend great though
uh the admiration uh is that i have of
him i i simply think that he's uh
mistaken in his views and uh i i urge
him to i urge him to to reconsider upon
full consideration of the of the inquiry
demands
thank you very much uh mr speaker
the prime minister
told us and i'm quoting him i have
repeatedly been assured since these
allegations emerged
that there was no party and that no
covet rules were broken
we now know that
12 of the 16 parties are subject to a
police investigation
and that of the remaining four
the sue grey report says this that she's
seen a serious failure to observe the
high standards at number 10. she's seen
failures of leadership
failures of judgment
and
the prime minister thinks this is fine
so just how bad do things have to be
before he takes personal responsibility
does what everybody in this country
wants him to do and resign
mr speaker what we are doing is taking
the action that i've described
to set up a prime minister's department
to improve the operation at number 10
and we will be taking further steps mr
speaker in uh in the days ahead
remember
speaker the
uh inquiry has found there have been
serious failings and has suggested
there'll be changes in the uh the way
that uh number 10 is run and there's a
real opportunity now to take forward
this new office of the prime minister
and ensure further improvements are made
so we can carry on delivering because
what the party's opposite hate is the
fact that this government will carry on
delivering on the things that matter
most to people while also making sure
that the government's within number 10
is improved
i thank my right on my friend very very
much i think he's completely right and i
do think that uh the opposition of
course uh want to keep the uh their
focus trained on this that's the that's
their decision i think mr speaker i
think mr speaker what the people this
country want us to do is to get on with
the job that they want us to do and that
is to serve them mr speaker and to stop
talking frankly about ourselves
[Applause]
mr speaker there is no word in the
english language for a parent who has
lost a child
no equivalent of widow or orphan for
that particular horror
it is a loss that is literally beyond
words
a loss that hundreds and thousands of
parents
have tragically experienced during this
pandemic
many had to bury their children alone
many couldn't be there with them at the
end
meanwhile
number 10 parted
does the prime minister understand
does he care about the enormous hurt his
actions have caused to bereave families
across our country
will he finally accept
that the only decent thing that he can
do now is to resign
mr speaker i do
care deeply about the hurt that is felt
across the country
about the suggestion that
things were going on in number 10 that
were in contravention of the of the
kobit rules and i understand how deeply
people feel about this and how angry
that they are
and i and i've apologized uh several
times mr speaker but i must say that i
think we should wait for the outcome of
the inquiry by before jumping to the
conclusions
that he has and in the meantime we
should focus on the issues that matter
to the british people